am i
am i cool all right let's uh let's stick
with orange
for this video hey what's up guys my
name is jonah welcome back to
my game engine series where we now have
some colorful lights in the room to play
with let me know what color you guys
want to see in the comment section below
so we're right in the middle of
implementing an entity component system
if you guys didn't see the first video
in which we kind of took an introduction
to the specific library
that we'll be using then it'll be linked
up there and you can check it out
uh today we're going to be continuing on
with uh talking about entity
or ant which is the library we'll be
using as well as talking about how
entities are going to be fitting into
all of these components because so far
we've been talking a lot about different
components that we can actually have
as part of our um
like scene i guess but we need to also
talk about the entities
so uh let's and i always do this so
unprofessionally let's
fade into um the view here and we're
going to take a look at uh all the stuff
that we've got
inside the scene class so um i don't
think we could even run anything last
time which is why i didn't commit
anything
today what we're actually going to do is
we're going to try and get an entity
onto the screen
that actually renders something and that
is our task for today
i think that um instead of just talking
and showing you examples which is what i
did last time
now that we have a pretty concrete uh i
guess set of
skills i was going to say but now that
we have some information about the
library itself we can actually begin
using it for its intended purpose so
what we're going to do
is we're going to go into sandbox at the
moment the thing that runs i believe
is the sandbox 2d yep right over here
this is now going to be we want to
convert this maybe like we're rendering
a few different things here
if i um i don't know this stuff doesn't
compile
but i think everything else should so if
i just run this is a good starting point
um okay so much stuff going on here
quick quick little hot tip here maybe i
should move
you know what because we're all friends
here let's
uh let's just dynamically just move this
in the middle of the video
that's fine that's professional what i
can do is i can go with more of like a
streamer setup
as you can see i'm preparing for
streaming on twitch um i can maybe move
my face over here
i don't know let me know what you think
about the face cam um i can move it down
here but then that's just like
i don't know it's covering up the time
and that's really important for you guys
to see as well as
other things maybe i'll leave it here in
the middle because there's nothing
really going on in the middle
but it might be really annoying for you
guys to to actually um
[Music]
uh watch this i don't know if it's going
to get annoying because like for example
right here you can't even see half it
no that's stupid i'm doing a complete
180 on that
let's maybe put it um i'll leave it at
the top
let me know where you want the face cam
okay so uh
my point though with that and i'll try
and make sure this fits in here
is it it's really important you actually
take a look at the output window if
you're
still using the and i'll just leave this
here so that you guys can see it well
if you are still using the error list
which is
this thing right which i'll also put
over here
if you're still using the error list you
should stop that immediately
because i mean it's not bad to just get
a quick overview
as to what's going on but you can see
that like i mean this is telling us
get is not a member of and storage it
looks like the
actual uh like error if we double click
on it takes us to
nth code which as you can see like i
mean
obviously obviously the code inside and
will compile except it won't in this
case because
it's templated code and we're actually
we're actually
somehow providing something that doesn't
work and so it can't generate the
template and so we get the compile error
this kind of stuff is um you know
is is stuff that is extremely difficult
if not pretty much impossible to debug
just by reading the error list so if you
go to the output instead
because what happens is the error list
basically pauses the output text and
then tries to display some stuff here
but a lot of the times especially with
templates it displays
complete garbage here that is like you
know i mean it's the first line of the
whole error message basically
so if you go back and you can see you
you look at the output you'll see that
we tried to compile scene.cpp
and then you can see here that it failed
because git is not a member of
this like storage mesh component
whatever class i guess
with ant entity equals entity so that's
just telling us what the actual
entity template parameter here is set to
and then you can see that we have
another message saying see declaration
of this c reference
eventually it of course will come down
to our code
and this is where our error message is
actually coming from
so cncpp line 54 it says see reference
to fun okay it doesn't even matter
really
if we double click on this it's going to
take us to the actual code which is this
over here
that caused the issue and then we can
try and like debug that or do whatever
we want with it
and see what the problem was okay so
it's important that you actually take a
look
at this because if you don't then it's
going to be pretty much impossible to
debug this
and then we have some triple issues here
[Music]
and again it's going to probably come
down to template parameter illegal use
of type void i don't even know exactly
what's wrong with this line because
just from the top of um
uh like from the top of my head
well i don't even know if that makes
sense but anyway it looks fine to me
um so i'm not exactly sure i think group
dot get transformed
mesh component nt i must just be
misusing the api
maybe um
i don't know if group.get is a thing
actually i'm beginning to suspect that
it's because the mesh component is
super weird and it's kind of empty
but if we give it a default constructor
how will that change anything
okay so this is a very weird issue here
so i basically what i did is i added a
default constructor tool which probably
isn't even the problem but i added some
actual
data to it i think
because what happens potentially is if
the class is completely empty
it seems like it tries to like replace
it with a void or something
and to be honest i have no idea where
that's coming from
it might be coming from the way the
tuple class actually works inside
the c plus plus library
i'm not sure but basically if you have
an empty component that's i guess that's
treated like an empty struct is treated
as a special case and it does not
compile
so you need to make sure that you have
some kind of
data inside there and as you can see if
you do everything works anyway that is
weird and that's obviously not something
that we would actually encounter in the
real world because
we would never have a component that has
nothing in it but if we run this
um you know everything everything should
work and that's kind of that's great
um but anyway so the reason i wanted to
open this is just to kind of see this
scene
okay so we have these kind of red
squares let's try and actually add them
in as entities and maybe
i mean i'm not sure how much this is
going to work to be honest because it's
kind of one of those things that i feel
is either
all or nothing meaning you either
convert the whole scene to work like
this or you
you don't do any of it like i don't
think we can partially get this to
render
um at least uh well we can technically
but that would be kind of hacking it
but anyway so that's kind of our goal
our goal is to kind of
maybe create like an entity class and in
fact we might even talk more about empty
glasses next time at the moment we want
to actually see this in practice
and i'm going to add an on update
function uh with a
time step to the uh to
the scene where is time step is it just
in here um i'm going to add a non update
function with a timestamp to
the scene and then we're going to call
that obviously every frame and then we
have the opportunity
to actually do some rendering and stuff
here if we wanted to
so the way that we'll set this up is and
this will kind of be our test right
so inside editor layer which is actually
where everything happens
sorry i was in sandbox saying
everything's coming from sample
example layer and all that stuff i
forgot that we were actually um
inside the editor that's okay i've
recovered i've remembered um
let's go over here and um
maybe include hazel dot h
let's include hazel slash scene
h i'll just do it here um doesn't really
matter where
and then what we're going to do is we're
going to say ref scene
m scene this is going to be like our
active scene
might even call it active scene and then
over here i'm just going to create an
arc
we'll create a scene um i think the api
for that is create
ref it's a little bit different in hazel
dev because we've actually got our own
ref
reference counting system so sometimes
i need to take a second to remember how
all this works
um so we'll create a scene here and then
what i want to do obviously is
and this api doesn't really exist yet
but i'm going to want to i'm i'm going
to create all my entities here why do we
have hazel colon colon
everywhere let's just quickly get rid of
all of that i think that was because um
we copied this from sandbox and that
didn't have the hazelnamespace this
obviously does
so uh inside our rendering code
which i think at the moment does it
really happen no okay
so where do we render stuff at the
moment it's here isn't it
um and we bind our frame buffer okay
this stuff needs to be slightly reworked
but whatever we'll do it here
so what i kind of want to do is inside
update we'll
we'll just pretend that we do it here
we'll say active scene on update and
then the time step this
is where we're going to update our scene
update scene and obviously all the
rendering is going to be submitted and
like
will happen from here as well so that's
important at the moment we're doing it
from
this editor layer which obviously is not
correct we want it we want to be
rendering from the scene the scene is
what needs to be rendered
um so we'll do uh so that's where that
gets called but then over here i want to
also be able to create entities
obviously
so usually the way this works is you
tell the active scene or you tell
you tell a scene i want to create an
entity like
inside you an entity belonging to the
scene so usually um
i'll write something like create entity
and then that will return that will
return usually an
entity for me and we'll talk about that
a little bit
but ultimately what i want to do here um
is have some kind of function
which again we'll do this without like
making we'll do this like one step at a
time i have to remember that this video
is does not need to like i don't want it
to be too long
but ultimately what we would eventually
have is some kind of
entity create entity function that
returns an entity type which we'll
create in the next video
and we'll talk about how that is going
to work and what that's going to enable
us to do and how it's going to make our
lives easier but for now
it's going to return an end entity which
again is temporary code because we don't
want to be really
we don't want to be returning anything
to do with ant to our client
which in this case is the editor layer
um it should be completely 100 hazel's
api apart from like glm
um so uh so this is temporary basically
but it's just gonna
let us do stuff um and also uh it's
going to let us
explore and a little bit better so
create entity um
yeah okay let's just implement this so
again this will do
this will basically for the basics of
this it'll return
registry create so we now have an easy
way to create an entity we just call
this function
and then we get an entity back i can
just do auto entity like that
this is going to be like one of our one
of our red squares
so the idea now is i want to add a
component
to this square i want to add two things
a transform component's obviously
something that's very useful
i probably want to call the entity
something so there should be something
like a tag
component which is essentially going to
function as the entity name and then i
also want to give it maybe like a sprite
renderer component
or something that will just tell it hey
render this as a sprite render it as a
red square
so to accomplish all of that stuff and
we'll go through end here
but to accomplish all of that we need
some components obviously because the
components of
the actual like data that will tell our
systems what to actually do
or rather you know i mean during our
kind of scene update we're going to just
take a look at
all of the like sprite render sprite
renderer components get all the
transform components from all those
sprite renderer component entity
entities as well and then that way we
can actually
render a scene um because we'll be able
to go through all the sprites and render
them
at the given location locate then the
location is provided by
the transform component okay so to make
all of that happen
um let's go ahead and inside this scene
um folder i'm going to make a new
uh components i'm going to make a new
file called components.h i'm going to
put all of the components
in one and i'll zoom in i'll try and
zoom in more i know people have been
asking me to
so we'll try and do this at like 250
zoom or so
um i might by harbor just zoom out and
if i do i'm sorry
i'm going to try and make an effort to
actually stay at this zoom level at
least
um so inside here we're gonna have all
of our components so we'll have
transform component
i do like to actually call them you know
x component
um so i like to have the word component
in them the reason is that if it's just
transform if it's just
mesh like that might be good for like
the c-sharp api but even that's
debatable
um you know for scripting languages even
like i like to have the word component
in there because that way
it's not an actual like mesh it's a mesh
component
that distinction is important for me so
we'll have the transform in here
and then as i described in
wow this is so big let's unpin let's
pin that somehow or unpin it um yeah so
this is
basically what we want right uh we want
include glm let me know what you guys
think of this font size because
to me it's like it's almost a bit
difficult to work with like look at this
anyway whatever um so that's the
transform component
uh that has everything we would want in
a transform component
let's make a sprite
renderer component this is going to be
real simple for now
this is just going to be a color
glm vector color just like that
really really simple stuff um you could
initialize this to whatever you want
so transform we could set to mat four
one
color we could set to um you know we can
set it like that one one one one
or something like that you know we can
actually i wonder if i can just
just to make this cleaner if i can just
do that that would be nice
okay so transform is being initialized
with one which is identity matrix
because there's a constructor for that
and then
color will be initialized to one one one
one i think that's pretty reasonable
um that's just gonna give us some
sensible uh defaults so that stuff
doesn't necessarily need to be set all
the time
um uh other copy constructor
other dot color color i don't know why
like we don't need a copy constructor
wait what is this
maybe this was wrong oh this was from
mad4 yeah i was going to say like why
are we doing that
um this is just us being able to
i guess take in a color it's not a bad
idea
so that we can actually specify a color
like this and then just do color color
okay definitely not going to have any of
this because of course this is going to
contain much more than just a color
but i guess when we create a sprite we
might want to specify a color or a
texture and then
when we have textures in here we'll do
that as well and we might even do that
now
we'll see okay so now we have a few
components right
this stuff is really simple
i will actually include uh
i will actually include them here
components authorization cp file because
we'll need them here and i guess
i'll go into hazel.h and actually
include
hazelscene components over here
okay now with these components in mind
um
i'm going to zoom out to like 220. is
that fine let me know if that's fine
because like it's
really it's really hard to work i'm not
going to lie i mean i'll do it if you
guys want but
i need to make sure that it's even
something you want first um so over here
we'll do
uh and remember to add components to
the registry what i'll do at the moment
which is not
really what i want to do obviously but
what we'll do is we'll kind of return
this registry
so this is temporary we're going to be
removing this code
next episode um but we're going to
basically say enter registry
we'll just call we'll just say reg
because this is so temporary
um and it's going to return this
registry right
we'll obviously return it by reference
um that's it and then what we're going
to have to do
is do active scene registry
and then we can start doing all of our
all of our ant related code for adding
our components which we
obviously tested out here so we want to
do um
where is it registry in place and then
into which entity where where i'm
placing all of this
so we'll call in place we'll say square
because that's our square entity
and then we're going to in place a
transform component
and then the transform component we're
going to and this is just like the
constructor here so i can say like
you know identity or i can leave it
blank because by default it should be
identity of course so this is now the
transform and it should be in place for
our square
now i want to actually add a sprite
renderer component so we'll do the same
thing
except we'll say sprite renderer
component into the square and what are
we doing let's
set a color of it used to be a red
square let's maybe make it green so i'll
do 0
1 0
1 okay so we now have a green square
um now that's not happy with something
none of them match the argument list i
think it's just because we're not saying
it's a vect4
yeah okay so we need to be a bit more
explicit there for some reason
um so uh there we go maybe because it
matches
like what else is component like i don't
know i guess because it could be this
maybe i don't know
anyway um okay that's it that's it that
should be enough for us to now render a
green square okay
and that's it that's all we do we add it
to the active scene we set up its
components obviously this api will be
changed
next episode can't stress that enough
but i want to show you how to do it
through and as well
now that we've done that um you know
when we go and render everything which
happens here
let's go ahead and just like i mean well
we still need to do this i guess
um and remember this is stuff that we
ultimately will move into like
a class called scene renderer um in the
future
but for now you know let's make sure we
update the scene
maybe like here um begin scene
as well something that like you know
let's let's get rid of all of these
rotated quads and stuff like that we'll
see if we can at least draw the green
thing
um and then you know this as well this
was like our like
loop of stuff and like there's a lot of
stuff going on here i don't
really like like where i need to be um
let's get rid of these
scopes here profile scopes that was just
to test out the profiling system which
we're not really using at the moment
so let's get rid of this stuff um
because we don't care we want to make
the code a bit more simple
so whatever render or reset um stats
we'll do the
update stuff here um rotation all of
this stuff
you know what let's let's kind of get
rid of this this exists i'll
i'll get rid of it to clean it up but it
exists already inside the
um inside the sandbox and and the
sandbox 2d class i think so
we don't really need to deal with it
here we can always recover that code if
we wish
so um so just to uh kind of
clear things up right this is what we
have at the moment so
the thing the big thing that we need is
we obviously need a camera component
and in fact we might even add that now
um just to make things a bit easier
let's just try this first though so i'll
update the scene
in between render a begin and end
obviously not ideal but
it that should work technically in terms
of like how our code is going to run
so if i go back to scene and i go to on
update this is where the juicy code
begins
so at the moment what i kind of want is
this right
i want to actually go through a group of
transform
and sprite renderer components right
as i go through transform and sprite
renderer components
right and get them and i'll get them by
reference so that i'm not copying them
and
not doing any of that it's not too
harmful to copy them here but obviously
if we were trying to write to them we
would need to make sure we weren't
copying them
otherwise we would end up with not
writing anything to the original
component inside the entity
inside the entity of course um is like a
figure of speech because it's not
actually inside
the entity that's not where the storage
is it's an nc component system
but anyway so yeah so we've got a sprite
renderer sprite to render a component
i'll just call it sprite um so now we
can actually render it so i can just be
like
renderer draw render 2d
um draw quad uh i might need to draw
like a rotated quad
i don't know um do we have a function
that can take in a matrix i really hope
that we do but
i have a feeling we don't
we still don't it's like the first thing
you want to do i can't believe it's not
in here
okay
static this is like the most important
function here which is static void draw
quad
and instead of taking in a position a
size and all of that stuff
right it should take in a
glm mass for
transform okay so we're drawing a quad
based on a transform
okay um with a color
that's all we need this is the really
really basic stuff that i
am shocked that we still don't have to
be honest
um and then we also want this so a
version that can draw textures
okay so with these two armed with these
two let's create them now
um for like for a 2d game you probably
don't need a transform which makes sense
that that's the case but usually
obviously with engines we
tend to like transform so we're going to
use them instead um
now coming over here um you can see that
we we have a transform that we're
calculating anyway which is why
it makes sense that this stuff exists
and we probably want to rewire this a
little bit to go through one code path
um i might do that next time ultimately
what i want to do here
is actually take this which is the thing
that renders with a color
i'll copy this entire function and again
we'll we will consolidate this code a
bit later
um so instead of this transform we've
got a transform right
so that's kind of it and you can see
that's that's really it
actually we just do a transform for each
vertex
that will have the translation rotation
scale information inside it
color stays the same and we're kind of
done right so
ultimately um i guess we can consolidate
it now because it's not not that much
work
if we scroll up what we the only thing
we really need to do
um inside this thing is when we figure
out the transform we need to figure out
the transform
and then draw quad with a transform and
a color
that's it right and that should work
um i should probably test that but i'm
going to say straight away that should
pretty much work
because all we're doing is constructing
a transform and then
um putting like the code path giving it
into that code path that takes in a
transform
and that is it so
um the texture one let's do the texture
one as well
so i'll copy the texture one which is
this um
and i'll paste it into here
isn't the texture one supposed to be
this is supposed to be underneath
i don't know why it's all the way up
there
we'll paste that in transform goes away
and then in the other one the opposite
happens so
transform stays everything else goes
away
draw quad so we do
transform texture
tiling factor all right done
i think that's it so now what we can do
now we've extended that api a bit is we
can just draw quad
transform and then sprite dot color
and that's it that's that's that's how
easy it is okay
um it's really simple so
include hazel renderer
renderer 2d to get that and that's it
now obviously begin end is something
that we need to talk about
um but ultimately we're doing it at the
moment inside the editor layout and
we're just doing on update which happens
to do the whole rendering
stuff um but i believe that should work
so let's get rid of maybe
like this this kind of functions as our
demo at the moment
um so i will leave this um as just like
you know
i'll call this like ours call it i'll
just say ant example code
just to say writing a comment and
example code okay
this is the ant example code that we can
refer to as we kind of
do stuff with the entity component
system i don't know let's hit f5
let's this is exciting let's see what
happens
we should just see a green square i
think
look at that first try awesome amazing
and everything still works with our
camera everything's great
okay awesome i'm really happy with that
um
now the square color you know we've had
this variable floating here for years
and it does nothing let's make it do
something
let's say that the square color let's
actually point this into
and this is this is how we can retrieve
this is a good test
um to retrieve like components and stuff
like that we basically want this
so we'll do um this
square entity that we have we'll keep
that
so i'll say um and
square entity we will keep
that over here we could have assigned it
later maybe i will just because this is
a bit of a demo and we might remove it
later
it's just it's just not it's just a
32-bit unsigned end so it's totally fine
to copy and everything
of course um and then we'll do
uh m active scene reg
get sprite renderer component
from square entity dot
color and that's it that's actually what
we need we can take a reference to that
we can stick it right in here but to
make things easier
we'll take a reference from it so this
is our
square color
and then we'll just stick that into here
put a semicolon there
see that into here okay and now we
should be editing directly the color of
the square and it should
we should get that visual feedback and
everything should be instant right so
here it is oh look at that
right we can edit the color this is much
like my room was looking earlier
um but we can now edit this color and
everything's great okay
so that um that's we're going to end it
here i think
that is let me just awkwardly switch
back to camera
um that is the introduction to this is
the second introduction i guess into
component systems this is how
everything's going to work i hope this
video
was a little bit insightful for how
we're going to be structuring this whole
scene and entity component system and
how they're going to be working together
as you can see it is super simple the
code is not going to change from what
you saw
here today the api will but the actual
underlying code that we're calling
is largely going to remain the same the
biggest problem at the moment is just
how we handle
scene rendering because we're kind of
doing half the stuff in editor layer
we're doing half the stuff inside this
scene class it's not really
good at all and it's going to break if
we try and do anything remotely advanced
but the actual entity component system
code here
like the way that we're making new
entities and adding components and
retrieving components
that api is going to be improved in a
bit more hazely but it's going to more
or less work in the same way
hope you guys enjoyed this video if you
did please don't forget to hit the like
button and also help support the series
on patreon.com huge thank you to
everyone
who does support the series don't forget
you can get access to beautiful 3d stuff
inside hazel dev inside hazeldev
um and also access like live streams
where i develop this stuff and
um you know if you're interested in
jumping ahead
and you want to you want to maybe
challenge yourself and have a go at
actually taking this existing
public code and trying to implement the
entity component system on top of that
and you want a little bit of guidance
then checking out the halodev branch is
also a really good way to kind of
challenge yourself
and uh and improve and practice um with
taking the kind of code there and using
it as a guide
and trying to integrate it yourself into
this public version i think that's a
really good exercise
and something that uh that i encourage
you to do
thank you for watching i will see you
next time where we're going to
basically be improving that entity api
we'll probably also create like a camera
component move that into the
anti-component system and try and more
or less make this an
actual proper ecs demo thank you for
watching i'll see you next time goodbye
[Music]
you